hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to hey
kids it's best not to do drugs why
because it's bad for you what kills your
brain cells and makes you stupid you
could get arrested for it and it's
really really addicted which means that
it's hard to stop doing so if you don't
want to go through all that stuff just
stay away from drugs why is that so hard
just tell your kids the truth and
they'll get the idea but no public
service announcements want scare the
shit out of us by making it look like
drugs came from the depth and if you
take drugs you turn into one of his evil
little minions these PSAs were so
far-fetched you couldn't help but laugh
at them which is why today I am bringing
you the top 11 greatest drug PSAs
ever why top 11 because I like to go one
step beyond so pull up a couch and enjoy
what I'm sure is medicinal in your hand
this is the top 11 greatest nostalgic
drug PSA
number one I used to see this one all
the time when I was a kid and to be
honest I kind of liked it it was short
sweet and had a lot of energy to it but
here's the thing their tagline is be and
original so wouldn't that technically
mean not listening to what the TV is
telling me to do it's kind of like a
weird Zen riddle if I do what the TV
tells me I won't be an original but if I
don't do what the TV tells me I'll be
following everyone else gotta which I
have some drugs my other problem with
this is that the drugs in this PSA don't
even look like drugs they look like some
sort of weird alien technology
the real tagline should have been just
saying no to radioactive grab legal
plaques because intergalactic crack is
wack other time this one starts off with
a father talking to his 13 year old son
I figured when you were old enough I'd
talk to you about drugs okay what this
doesn't seem too bad after all it is
important to talk to your kids about
drugs and make sure that they don't go
down the wrong path oh my god he's dead
he's dead he's talking to a dead boy
he's dead drugs took his life oh my god
what a twist
he just em nice shovel on my ass you
know there was a lot of PSAs about how
parents should talk to their kids about
drugs but they were always shown during
Saturday morning cartoons and if you're
like every other parent in the world
you haven't woken up to see Saturday
morning in years it's your day off and
you're gonna sleep sleep like the dead
oh sorry I didn't mean that deadline um
condolences if you don't teach your kids
to say no to drugs it's as good as
saying yes number die there's a weird
little PSA that actually gives drugs
it's very own theme song is it me or
does it sound like this PSA is actually
promoting drugs
and if that's not bad enough there's
actually parts of the song where they
talk about the good things that drugs do
you mixing the signal their gags not to
be fair they do talk about bad drugs too
but it's hard to hear because you can
barely make it out that are sure to have
a Pau the struggle
let's struggle with the law I don't know
which are good and which are bad the way
you're saying it I don't even know what
the hell drugs on number eight though
this really isn't as much about drugs as
it is about smoking this star wars PSA
definitely deserves mentioning why
because it actually shows r2d2 lining up
what the hell I didn't even know robots
have lungs to damage well I can't think
poking it's grabbing up at all yes now
golden robots and trash cans on wheels
that's very adult seriously who even
knew r2d2 was addicted cigarettes are
hard to beat and my guess is that r2
didn't back down quite as easily as they
let on huh don't on fire
Natsuki do you find a cigarette well I
didn't think smoking it's grown up at
all then he does dreadful things to your
lungs is very bad for your heart but I
know I don't have one but humans do and
I think we should set a good example
describe you well done artoo breaking a
habit is hard don't smoke no sir
this one is just weird it doesn't even
really say drugs are bad or anything it
just well watch it
I do coke so I can work longer so I can
earn more so I can do more coke so I can
earn more so I can choose yeah
never let David Lynch director drug PSA
I mean that makes no sense so the guy
does some coke runs around like the
roadrunner that disappears into at the
end credit I never even saw a PSA they
had a DN credit before my guess is that
they commissioned the writer from The
Shining to write this shit up and they
just put some visuals in at the end how
do you like it
notices this is another one that has one
of those quote unquote twist endings
it's just a woman who's about to take a
dive in the pool while the narrator
talks about drugs doing drugs just like
being on top of the world everyone says
so ok no problem so far nothing really
fast going I guess the waters the water
the pool oh my god no matter the pool oh
my god what's West
honestly I don't supposed to be
horrified by this but all I'm really
think about is if the marks you looked
at the pool look like this you know that
kind of wildly coyote look I don't think
her hair would weigh so much that would
leave an indent but you get the idea
you just been late you're jumping into
number 5
hey yeah remember this guy have you ever
pissed yourself in your sleep you knew
this creepy guy starts off that's just
some loud-talking drug dealer but that
slowly turns into the scary-looking guy
no Ryan
we snake dealing in
your choice tip will hit and you'll do
anything the cock seal from your mama
not cheat on your whole boys but hey do
I look like the kind of guy that would
do that you look kid like you
yes daughter number four oh I love this
one and again it has something of a
twisted sure yeah I mother said she
comes in your closet I don't know what I
guys lost of what look that is why don't
you get it dad answer me answer me you
little punk who taught you how to do
this stuff
who told you to do this stuff you're
alright
I learned it by watching you oh you
stole my watch you bastard I'll kill you
I actually I love this PSA because I
always wondered how the conversation
went afterwards I told you to do this
son
yeah well you are high while you're
doing it oh yeah yeah that makes sense
so did you ever figure out where to buy
the filters for the bombs
well most places like Ace Hardware don't
sell anymore you know for this exact
reason of course but there's still a lot
of places online back to cook you up and
for reasonable prices do really only a
few cheap I've taught you well son well
I had a good teacher now that's a PSA I
will listen to parents who use drugs
have children who use drugs another
Greek people know this one so well they
could say it interstate this is drugs
this is your brain on drugs
any questions this is probably one of
the best well known PSAs ever but why I
think it's because everybody had a witty
retort to say right after the PSA was
over for example here's a few I turn
throwing up any questions oh can you
serve my brain with a side order of
bacon any questions
is that me with real brains or
substitution grand ears any questions
can I get mine as a brain benefit any
questions it's a true you can't make an
omelet without breaking some brains any
questions with this technically be
considered brain food any questions is
my brain part of a complete breakfast
any questions are you gonna eat my brain
cuz I'm really hungry mostly from doing
drugs actually this PSA was so popular
they spawned a sequel PSA with this
fucking crazy one this is your brain
this is heroin this is what happens to
your brain after snorting heroin this
what your body goes through
this is what your family goes
sure any questions yeah what the hell
kind of drugs are you on number two this
is personally one of my favorites it
starts off with the kid in school being
teased by the world's most generic and
probably youngest drug dealer one
chicken did you ever in all your years
actually know a bully that actually went
bright suddenly we cut to a classroom
where the Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles
are apparently teaching a class of
kindergartners oh dude I'm going to that
class growing up so the kindergartners
say that Joey should get out of there
yeah got it let's see if Joey's that
smart and then Joey comes up with the
greatest comeback line in the history of
victorious zingers I'm not chicken
you're a turkey wow that that's cosmic I
mean you will never hear a greater
defense in all of junior high history oh
this insult was so good that the bully
had no choice but to stuff himself in
his own locker where he hanged himself
with the straps of his backpack it is
that and the number one greatest the
Statue Club PSA is
Wow what is this it must be serious
you
this is crack rock cocaine it isn't
glamorous or cool or kid stuff it's the
most addictive kind of cocaine and it
can kill you what's really bad is nobody
knows how much it takes so every time
you use it you risk dying it isn't worth
it look everybody wants to be cool but
doing it with crack isn't just wrong it
could be dead wrong oh where do I start
first of all look at this show and tell
me it isn't somehow inspired by an
illegal substance no sober person could
possibly come up with this second do he
play a drug dealer in the movie blow
isn't that just a little contradictory
to what's being said here third this is
just a few weeks before the infamous
movie theater scandal where Paul Reubens
was found whacking off in public kind of
a mixed message there peewee I mean how
do you think the follow-up PSA for this
went hey kids
just remember crack is wack but lacks
the smack so whack off whenever you can
last but definitely not least pee-wee
Herman talking to me about crack is
absolutely hilarious if it was Paul
Reubens the actor who played peewee
telling me about crack maybe that could
work but when pee-wee Herman not Paul
Reubens says this is crack I die a
little inside I've died of laughter and
I know I look very collected and pulled
together right now but when I first saw
this I had to go through hours and hours
of laughter to get to this point I mean
that hours of oxygen probably taken off
the end of my life that I will never get
back it is that hilarious
look I love pee-wee Herman but this is
just insane
most of these drunk PSAs are instead of
being truthful or honest drug psays just
want to scare us and not question the
truth behind this government propaganda
I guess they have good intentions but is
it really worth it to go so over-the-top
subject matter that many of us probably
would have even known about until we
heard about it on TV yes okay okay just
don't show me that guy again I'm done
establish your credit I remember it so
you don't have to yes